of course Ricky you famously became
friends with your kind of musical hero
two extras Oh
David Bowie yeah yeah he was my hero for
music for about 25 years and yeah then I
I met him and I invited him to do extras
and he said yes just incredible i
co-wrote a song with him that this song
we'll be singing extras and I am I sent
him the lyrics and I called him up and I
said you got the lyrics he went yeah I
said them yeah I said can you give me
some sort of like retro like life on
Mars and he went yeah I'll just knock
off a quick [ __ ] life on Mars
[Laughter]
I'll do that amazing it was amazing to
the end just incredible an artist to the
end and kept putting out material right
to the end it was incredible and did you
just get in touch because of extras who
you were friends anyway no well the
first time I met him I was sort of newly
famous and I was invited to one of those
things at the BBC like the office had
just come out I think on DVD the first
year and I was invited by Greg Dyke who
was the director general then and then
we went the swatch David Bowie's a few
other people and then after Greg Dyke
come up to me said oh you're a big Barry
fan like I said yeah I loved him I said
come and meet him and I went really
yeah come on come on right and there's
me and Jane and Greg Dyke walking to me
go by and all the way when Salman Salman
Rushdie joined us we went that day but
he was very polite he didn't know I was
um I remember the next day I was in the
pub with my mate and he said what'd you
do last night and I went nothing an
email from David Bowie saying so I
watched the office what do I do now
and we sort of became pen pals i
inviting directors then he invited me to
play a benefit in New York my first New
York gig at Madison Square Garden and he
introduced me and the crowd didn't knows
me there and they went crazy and he just
came out with a harmonica and went yeah
shabby little loser and it was it was
amazing and that was his last live
appearance yeah incredible that's
extraordinary extraordinary yeah amazing
[Music]
you